need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation what's that believe
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and show
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being born in the Soviet Union and
hustling baseball cards and flowers as a
kid to becoming one of the most
sought-after celebrity entrepreneurs and
speakers around is Gary Vaynerchuk and
here's my take on his top 10 rules a
success vol 10 also if you want to know
at Gary Vee and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every
morning for the next 254 days I will
send you a video for free to help you
build your confidence the link to join
is in the description below the reason
people aren't patient is they value
other people's opinions too much
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one respect your ambitions I think most
people fear it being tough when they're
asking for something crazy do you know
how hard it is to be a millionaire it's
it's unbelievably hard yeah
99% of people in the world never even
remotely get close number one biggest
mistake all of you make is you don't
realize it's gonna take 21 years for
success 21 years Souza cuz now look most
people don't understand what it is to do
a million
everybody thinks everyone should do a
million a million a million I laugh at a
million 99% of the people watching this
video right now for 31 years from now
because everything will be online will
never taste a million ninety-nine
percent of you now when you internalize
that all of a sudden now you're gonna
respect what you're asking yeah I want
people to respect their audacious
ambitions more rule number two stop
overthinking things if the Internet is
where people's attention is you got
music posted on Instagram right now your
mind followers started everybody thinks
you need a million followers what if
you're one follower is you it's not
about how many it's who and what can
they do if you got SoundCloud and
Spotify and Instagram and YouTube guys T
grizzly comes out of jail after five
four and a half years yeah from being
locked up for a half decade to putting
out one video and a song if you've got
talent this is about talent sure and all
of a sudden 72 hours later twenty-one
Savage is DMing you so if you've got
flames and you've got bars and you're so
great
put it out but what's happening is
people are insecure of course people are
overthinking people are artists trying
to make it perfect sure it's ego rule
number three enjoy being underestimated
I was at eighty four thousand followers
on Instagram eighteen months ago after
being on it for five and a half years
eighty four thousand I don't think I'd
be at three point six million if I
thought about how to get from eighty
four thousand to a hundred thousand
correct people are smart and they'll get
you know what's funny they're smart in
the end they're not so smart in the
beginning people fall for you know
sizzle a lot i sandbagged myself because
i'm so in the long game yeah like Andy
and like my team like the biggest
complaint this little squad has is like
when can we start making the content
more about you being smart like that's
just not even a part of my narrative but
you have to understand why cuz that's
the leverage you know like I prefer
being underestimated by Madison Avenue
that's our strength you know still to
this day after everything that's out
there in our industry think vaynermedia
is mean with a bunch of interns still to
this day the fans aka anyone who had an
opinion about me said to me that a
website wouldn't work that email wasn't
better than direct mail that Google Ads
weren't as good as yellow pages that
YouTube was a fad that Twitter was
stupid that Facebook would never be more
than a college app that an agency was a
bad idea
that social media was ridiculous that
voice isn't going to be big
[ __ ] Ted
when you learn how to enjoy being
underestimated rule number four
work hard and smart how much time do you
spend a month you said those four things
how much time do you actually spend on
it in a day zero
sometimes I assume in a week how much do
you spend two hours great now is the
most important part of this meeting how
many hours do you sleep at night
great so I love the way you said it I
have to have seven so if I wanted to say
go to six so that you pick up five
you're gonna say to me Gary I have to
have seven right now let's go somewhere
else I have to know what you're doing
the other 17 hours I would bet the house
that we can find an hour every day I'm
guaranteeing because you might be
working all 17 hours but you might not
be working on something smarter than
spending an hour a day on the thing that
you're talking about do you understand
that's I mean look that's the answer the
answer is time you know people talk
about working hard and working smart the
answer is only both
you have to work hard and smart based on
your ambition if you want to build a
business for yourself that is like a 1%
life most people understand what
building a business for yourself is it's
very special it's very special trying to
build a business for yourself
everybody's doing now pulling it off
trying to play basketball everybody can
try being an NBA player trying to be a
rapper or a singer
everybody's doing pulling it off trying
to be a footballer an actress got it so
you're trying great pulling it off is
hard it takes everything time and smarts
you need seven I'm glad you said it that
way
because this makes this piece of content
more valuable it's the 17 other hours
I'll give an example a lot of people
drive to work for 45 minutes if they
took a bus for an hour and 15 minutes
they would save money and get more work
done
but do you have the humility to take the
bus course to drive in your car rule
number five know yourself there is no
one path the only path is like do you
know yourself and more importantly that
voice inside your own head a lot of
times people to understand that that was
put in your head a lot of people when
I'm like don't listen to anybody but
yourself
I'll get that DM they're like yo I love
that my problem is I'm telling myself I
suck and I'm not have to DM like yo you
didn't like that isn't you that's your
mom or dad that put that in your head
and now you believe it and you think
it's your own voice nobody starts off
thinking they suck here's the problem
and I'm not trying to be mean I'm trying
to make you happy and win most of the
people listen right now don't have the
talent that's ok and that is ok ok and
mate by the way some of the cats in this
room probably when you guys were seven
eight nine ten eleven might have thought
you wanted to be the artist and what I
would say is kudos to you to be like
yeah look that you understood that that
what you are gonna be you know Queen
Latifah that's it you know what I love I
love perspective if you're listening to
this right now it means you have the
ability to listen to this right now
which means you live in America it means
that you have some sort of device that
allows you to listen to this I just
don't think people understand how lucky
they have it no matter how she think
they have it rule number six find
happiness you gotta figure out what
makes you happy on your turn
that's okay though that's the text
I think your dwelling and putting more
compounded pressure on yourself for
something that every 21 year-old is
living the only 21 year olds know so you
can have your shoes on so go for the
race but I'm telling you make it the
process of life not some sort of goal
even the Jets things the front I want to
try to buy the Jets but it really means
I love the process so much that I want
to do something so big
really so I could do the process buying
the Jets I want the process of trying it
you gotta fall in love with doing
something every day not what the folks
are gonna get you or what the goal is
that arbitration up there's something
serious just what do you like to do do
it and eat on it and if that's being an
artist and you can only eat like a
McDonald's everyday then you're good you
got to fall in love with the thing you
gotta get that place rule number seven
make a choice you're not gonna invest as
much as properly needed because you want
to buy stuff
by the way Mazel Tov enjoy you do you
but that's the debate yeah because I
love USA come out of my comfort zone but
I just [ __ ] love the facility this is
this is why mazelTov just don't complain
when your business doesn't grow that
much over the next decade yeah
you're not eating your business you're
feeding yourself good but you better
shut up about why am I not growing you
know why you're not growing you're not
feeding it so they answer your question
why do I do it cuz I love the process
more than the other stuff you love the
other stuff more than the process that's
okay I don't think I'm right that's just
who we are so I'll probably build
billion-dollar companies and you won't
doesn't mean I'm right you might have
more vacations and eat more food and go
to more matches and spend more time with
people that's great
life is about choices but you can't have
both
and I think when there's a moment in
time that's special like this it's
probably a good idea to take advantage
of it because you can go back to being
comfortable three years later and oh by
the way that comfortable tends to be far
better than it was three years earlier
rule number eight chase admiration I'm
not a motivational speaker that wants
you to pay me $5,000 to be your coach I
don't want your money
no I don't want anything super shots
fired super shots fired when people say
they want to change your life but real
quick give me six thousand to do it
you're not changing I'm chasing
admiration my guy that's right you know
what admiration feels like like if
anybody's got it out there if you have
some one person your little nice you
know like so many admiration like do you
know what I felt like coming in here
tonight
so good taking picture with her in front
like that's nice that I knew how to make
money I know how to make money I don't
need the people watching me on the gram
or YouTube or my podcast to give me
their money
I've always known how to do that I want
your admiration rule number nine be
secure in yourself be like clusters
earned I'm like cool that seems slow and
egotistical its offense I think people
say no too often because they fear
ramifications
I don't think micro losses are scary and
empowering people to make decisions is
how you scale and to me I've always
thought that somebody doing in 86
instead of my hundred is better than not
doing it at all plus how am I ever gonna
learn if somebody is capable without
giving them a chance like eventually you
have to let your kids swim eventually
you have to let them swing the back and
so yeah I'm I'm I'm completely not
driven by fear and people are and the
reason people don't let people do things
as they fear it or they have I mean it's
ego a lot of people don't want their are
under studies or their direct reports or
the people they manage to be better at
something than them it's just insecurity
I'm massively secure in myself and then
I
that's exactly right cable it's a good
insight you're doing a good job with
this
and asking me these questions like I say
yes I give trust at first you can lose
it people like clusters earned I'm like
cool that seems slow and egotistical
like Who am I to have it earned you know
like great like that to me trust is
given and then you lose it if your face
uncapable incapable excuse me and and
I've proven that you're not you're not
worthy of the challenge or the or the
role and rule number ten the last one
before a very special bonus clip is stop
complaining you need to ask yourself
tonight why it's more interesting to
dwell and complain and come up with
excuses than actually be happy
I'll save you time your mom you up so
cool right or your dad or your older
brother or some circumstance here's my
big thing I'm looking around and even
for the geezers in here you're all
living for another fifty years minimum
there's people and hid right I mean dude
I know I know you're like awesome right
cuz even when you were kids you're like
sixty yet now
now right now but you know it's crazy
now it is not like how many of you here
under 30 all of you outside of like
devastate that scale almost all of you
get to a hundred hundred ten easy that's
nuts
you're you freaking out you turn 30 and
you were living for another ninety four
years
feel like I don't have my together I'm
like you started
now I've got a really special bonus tip
from Gera and how to grind that I think
you're gonna really enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or in your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what do
you need to stop complaining about
number two what's one choice that you
need to make that you've been putting
off and number three what are you
overthinking and will get to work on
today
for me the biggest thing about this is
this is what I want kids to think
entrepreneurship is this is what I care
about everybody wants to come up with
the uber of waffles I'm gonna build an
app and like build the next sneaker
marketplace and everybody's so
impractical like no one you know
and put your head down for a decade and
then look up but nobody wants to do that
that's what I wanted you to meet him
because you know memorize just the whole
way selling pickles out of a wooden
nickels yeah I think what that people
laughed at him right you already mean
well that by the way that to me is the
most important part of the story yeah
the reason these kids aren't doing
anything is because they're worried
about people's judgement they can't be
bothered selling pickles out of a cart
they're too busy trying to get to the
Hamptons jump on a swan and put it on
Instagram but to do that we're gonna
sell pickles for ten years then you can
own a house in the Hamptons you were
executing my god I executed to nobody
nobody heard a peep for me for 12 years
I put my head that was a liquor store
yeah everything day didn't have a word
to say to nobody everybody's trying to
come out there everybody's trying to
come out the gate and say I'm an
entrepreneur I'm like cool I'm a
basketball player do you make money
entrepreneur yeah like literally people
go print 10 t-shirts with some word and
decide that's their supreme right and
they're like yo I'm an entrepreneur I'm
like cool I'm an actor like you know
like do you get paid are you winning
as well as long media the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
if you want more Gary check that the top
50 rules to success video I did on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you're gonna enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there Wehling on what you up on is the
quickest way for the next thing not to
work take life by its throat